now let me pick up off of something
you're doing on your sheet right now
good look at that area and proven up for
a variety of shapes and we look that the
circle is special the circle is special
because it doesn't have any straight
edges right so that's right it doesn't
have edges full stars oh I suppose it's
a Shh
what are you ready now it's interesting
you say that because you're kind of
right kind of right but I'm and this is
if you're Miami for next year this is
the difference between mathematics and
physics right physics is interested in
what you can measure and what's actually
there where's maths a lot of which
physics is based on right can imagine
things which aren't necessarily don't
exist in the real world so we can
imagine a perfectly round circle even if
you can't make one in real life
so we can't consider it even if you
can't find one and hold it in touch now
very quickly let's think about the area
and perimeter of this thing remember
what the formulas are for okay so we've
got perimeter which is around right and
then in for a circle it's got a special
name which is the circumference so
sometimes they call it C right and
that's two times pi that we don't know
MA
times the radius now that's the
cumference
that's all the way around okay I'll give
you chip bhai if you remember which ones
which in a second okay area is the other
formula what is the other formula is PI
R squared good now here's how I remember
which ones which because they look very
similar don't they okay um think about
we've been thinking about length and
area and how they're different do you
remember that okay
so just an example what units my the
circumference being like how do we
measure
you might say it might be in like
centimeters old meters or something like
that
cm for example but area isn't in
centimeters right it's in square
centimeters isn't it yeah something like
that okay so you can see that with an
area you've got things squared and
that's why you've got this square right
for the same reason
where is with the circumference you're
at how many squares right that's why
there's no square there it's just a 1
okay so they look very similar that's
how you can now helps remember them
because really the reason why this is
squared is because it's a centimetres
measurement of length times another cent
means measure yep well in this case
premia has a special name circumference
so it's agreed
okay now we're looking at a different
kind of shape that's related to circles
it's called a sector right the way I
think it was checked off and it's like
it's like a piece of pie or a piece of
pizza
so for instance draw a radius in the
circle that you've got there and then
drew another radius somewhere else okay
so for instance if I go down okay this
shape here and I might I might shade it
so you can see exactly what I'm talking
about this shape here
yeah yeah they are kind of cold
that's right because this shape is a
sector okay so there is house it up it's
a piece of pie okay that's pretty bad
even for me now if I just want to work
out the area of the sector audits
uttered how do I go about doing that let
me just draw it separately over here
right well it looks kind of like this if
I want to I get its area how do I go
about doing it okay well let me give you
an example suppose suppose that was a
right angle over there okay
what's the science of writing how many
now hold on a second if that's 90 how
big is it to go all the way around the
circle how many degrees it's 360 degrees
to go all the way around so this is a
quarter okay right right so if I want to
work out this area let's actually let's
actually put some numbers on it shall we
suppose your circle had a radius of 10
centimeters okay
what would be the whole area the whole
area would be PI R squared hours 10 so R
squared is 100 right
sorry
where were we
last weird right Polly times a square as
I asked him so a squared 100 see you get
you're gonna get a hundred PI
centimeters squared
yes okay now you guys just told me that
this is shaping this sector is a quarter
the size of the whole thing
right so therefore its area should also
be a corner yeah does that make sense so
I'm gonna say the area of this sector
right is a quarter of whatever the area
the whole thing 100 PI centimeter square
what is a quarter hundred twenty-five
good okay so there you go there's the
area and if you wanted to you could get
a calculator out work out what 25 times
pi years I'm guessing it's something
like 77 or 78 thereabouts here before
but let's try a different angle suppose
I made it a bit smaller okay
suppose the owner of pick up I want to
pick up a bit of a more difficult angle
yeah let's get 54
that's a terrible trouble okay so what
is 54 look like 54 something like this
54 degrees I'm just guessing
okay now if that's 54 degrees
it's still the same 10 centimeter circle
how can we go about doing it now it's
not a quarter is it and it's not a it so
it's a it's a weird awkward number and I
could make up any degree there and it'll
be a bit difficult right so tell me how
did you get caught how did you notice so
quickly that 90 degrees was a quarter of
360 yep
you can say you can say there are four
90s in this right for 90s and riches
riches right turn knew what you meant to
say right I I could hear it in there
okay
now let me say that another way for
nighties
that's your 360 right another way of
saying this is 90 degrees over 360
science of six that's a quarter see that
right here with 360 you can put any
calculator vedic ribbit so if i want to
know or what about 54 i want to know
what fraction that represents okay well
I'm gonna go instead of 19 over 360 it's
going to be 54 over 360 okay I don't
actually know what that is but I don't
need to write because it's still going
to give me the right proportion
that's how much of the circle I'm
interested in now let's just check that
value about just for the sake of it
because we can write 54
three oh I can't now if you put that
into your calculator I'll tell you point
one five that's 15 percent does that
look like it's about 15 percent of the
circle yeah like you can you can get
like another almost almost eight of them
all the way around okay I think it
sounds about right
so we did that one quarter times the
whole circle we're now going to go fifty
four times three sixty three to four one
three six up the whole circle which i
think is fifty okay so anytime you want
to work out what's the area of just part
of the circle okay they'll give you an
angle they'll tell you how much of the
circle they're interested in okay and
you're gonna stick up here that's the
important part right there that's where
the area belongs you divide by 360 why
we divide by 360 remember because that's
the whole circle so 54 over 360s how
much of the circle you're interested in
who you don't let the whole lot okay
right okay maybe see if we push back on
this little walkers we're not just
interested in area we're also interested
in circumference okay so let's have a
got this guy have you got this
so this is a quarter of the circle
wasn't it right so therefore if I were
to work out this yeah
the curvy bit right that should be a
quarter of the whole circumference yes
perimeter equals 1/4 times the
circumference which is 2 PI R which in
this case would be 20 PI centimeters
okay so 1/4 of 20 pi centimeters now I
can work that as well
but that's only this curvy part over
here what did we define prove it out
it's the length just examine all the way
around that's right I'm missing two
parts I'm missing this part and I'm also
missing this part but you guys know what
they're equal to don't you that's that's
the radius yeah that's right they're
both 10 so you're 10 centimeters here 10
centimeter here so far what the whole
perimeter what else do I need to add on
to this - ba - 10
okay said all right what's a quarter of
25 it's a quarter 25 it's fine
so b5 Pike and then you've got 2 times
10 which is 20 and that's how many
centimeters I've got okay let's go to
this one because this one is harder
right the perimeter is going to be
auslan
I've got a quarter here but I don't know
a quarter here do I like that that's how
much of the circle of interesting so
I'll go 54 over and 360 times the
circumference which is 25 okay now
that's just the curvy bit so what else
do I have to add four straight paths
right which is still 2 times 10 because
it's still the same radius 2 times 10
okay now that I think I think that'll be
3 you can go check it out